hallöchen meiner lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen mod
vorstellung und zwar von der simcity
modifikation und wer bist du denn so und
damit herzlich willkommen zur
modifikation an sich ja ihr habt richtig
gehört sind die modifikation city in
minecraft ja das ist möglich
ich werde euch das ganze ganz kurz alles
zeigen das ist eine sehr umfassende
modifikationen englischen top donnell
ford ford höhe der vater namen erhöhe
das heißt wir werden mit diesem top das
ganze ist ein bisschen durchgehende todd
rogers wie ein mob einfach der als
einfach nur ein typ und naja also man
kann mit dieser simcity modifikationen
findet allerdings natürlich wie man die
beschreibung uns selbst auszuprobieren
ihr könnt eure eigene stadt aufbauen und
zwar das ganze ganze automatisch
beziehungsweise automatisiert ich fange
erst mal mit ganz grundlegende sachen an
ich bin den garten creative mode und
erst mal wenn ihr eine neue welt startet
werdet ihr gefragt wollt ihr das mit
symbolkraft starten ohne sehkraft oder
im creative city kraft mode das sind die
unterschiede einfach ohne sehkraft ist
halt ganz normale welt als nix mit
simcity hiermit da zugefügt worden
normal 10 kraft ist das was ich gerade
das was dann hat man halt eine begrenzte
anzahl an den krediten also an den
credits an den geld und dann gibt es
dieses creative wo man dann einfach ganz
ganz viel geld hat und alles machen kann
ich zeige euch jetzt mal ganz kurz die
kräftigen rezept und zwar findet ihr die
ganzen sachen hier unter verschiedenes
das einzige was wir allerdings erstmal
brauchen sind die 10 mio marke die
mining box farming box und der erst im
dezember building construction seminar
kann macht ihr indem ihr einfach
löwenzahn gelb also gelbe farbe und
darunter einen stopp dann bekommt ihr
110 mio wer braucht eigentlich nur drei
die komplette zeit also sehr leicht zu
machen diesen dieses in mining box
bekommt drei eichen holzbrettern also
drei wurden place dann hier fünf
kubikmeter eine stein spitzhacke muss
stein sein kann nichts anderes sein und
meine dürften nicht eure diamant
spitzhacke verwenden wenn es dann und
das geld
oben für die semi building construction
genoss reichen mit einem wert bank in
der mitte und für simyo farming box
natürlich eine holzhacker elite so dann
bekommt ihr die drei sachen die ich hier
habe beziehungsweise dann ob die marca
wenn wir nun anfangen wollen zu bauen
also jetzt eine weltweite bekommt ihr
immer einen typen der einfach neben euch
sport spricht euch wenn wir zu euch wird
wenn ich zb times hatte hörte ich glaub
ich ein paar sounds ach schade hat man
sich wenn man vorhin das ist jetzt echt
wird wohin als nacht war was ich mal
ganz kurz offen nacht times at night
time that 0
jetzt habe das gehörte zum beispiel
letztens und trainings ich kann jetzt
aufschlagen gehört ihr auch im sound der
das hat sehr wehgetan
naja ok ich würde sagen wir von jetzt
erst mal ganz kurz an und zwar sind
diese marker die position weiter
ausgebaut wird das heißt wir jetzt
hinsetzen steht ihr freund lässt und das
im chat liegt nur ganz kurz vor die
front
also das ist front leicht verletzten
macht nicht den fehler und selbst ihren
sehen wir dass es ja links davon von
vorn trifft sondern setzt hier eins
davon also das ist rechts davon so das
heißt ich setze sie einfach ein marker
hin also wenn ihr hier ein haus bauen
wollt dann schaut so dann setzt hier ein
noch ein marker hin zum beispiel hier so
jetzt habe ich finally player die relief
position also hier wieder dass es wieder
linksseitig setzen hier ein jordanier
camp mining box von mailboxen right
click wie front live marketing
constructor wir fangen jetzt erst mal an
mit der werte werte wie ich dafür
vorbereitet möchte mit der streaming box
harte hand habe ich wenn ich jetzt hier
den front live marke hatten müsst ihr
die box hier vor sitzen weil dann
realisiert qualität realisiert diese box
das hier dieser bereich ist wo
gearbeitet wird drin so ich kann jetzt
auf diese box einfach richtig drauf
machen und hier in meiner herren und
alles blablabla
es ist allerdings egal und zwar müsst
ihr erstmal eine truhe irgendwo hier ins
umfeld setzen könnte hier hinsetzen ihr
könnt ihr auch darüber setzen ja okay
das muss jetzt so sein aber ich werde
dir einfach mal eben hier hin
ach nein da so jetzt habe ich hier eine
truhe stehen und hier werden nachher die
ganzen sachen rein kommen die aus dieser
mine quasi rauskommen so ich kann jetzt
einfach offheim einer drücken da habe
ich allerdings zurzeit kein weil dieser
typ s place at least one jazz storage
blocken jetzt constructed blog so hätte
ich spreche da jetzt mal ganz kurz in
constructor blog erst mal seine box
blabla marin l
so bilden gepaart mit modul 180 da ist
mein haus auch du vollkommen machen
bekomme ich vor dem antritt soll das
manchmal nicht hier
da so feiern was euch nicht hier
ablenken der weiß auch grad mit einer
anderen sache beschäftigt es war
wahrlich vor den test gemacht habe jetzt
kann ich einfach auf haie meiner gegend
ottendorf ort okay jetzt habe ich den
zeugen also angeheuert und der steht
jetzt bei mir jetzt kann ich einerseits
keyboard blog teils machen also eine
mine ist ja wie alle wisst ich habe
heuer den an und der gerät sich dann
hier einfach und hat danach ganz ganz
viele blöcke also dass ich einfach
blöcke durch den kriege oder eher sollen
dort blöcke wegschmeißen oder der soll
dort und steine wegschmeißen oder dirt
und sand oder der soll dort sand und
stein wegschmeißen und metern zum
beispiel nur die ärzte wieder behalten
ich mach einfach der soll alles behalten
und dann gibt es die möglichkeit cover
of glass dann machte das glas darüber
das heißt da kann ich da nicht rein
fallen allerdings muss ich dafür glas in
diese kiste rein tun möchte ich
natürlich nicht weil ich habe keinen
glas allerdings deswegen sage ich lief
mein open mit richtig einfach auf dann
jetzt seht ihr der trommel fort die dggg
wenn ihr wisst wovon das ist dann schon
mal die kommentare war ein paar fehler
mining erde also der meint erde also das
heißt also plötzlich das halt auf
deutsch gestellt habe und er ist einer
meiner der hat kein zuhause als erste
single und er ist ein wenig hungrig so
der gräbt sich jetzt hier runter oder
das problem ist da ist direkt so eine
fette höhe herunter na gut da tut mir
leid tut das weiß natürlich ein blödes
beispiel dass sie direkt der fahner höhe
drunter ist okay das war jetzt wirklich
total blöd
das hätte vielleicht besser planen
sollen gehört ich lass dich hier einfach
der der der wird sich jetzt selber im
weg eigentlich raussuchen
schau mal ganz günstig versucht immer zu
helfen so ich kann ich ja hier einfach
sein den weg versuchen herauszukitzeln
wo gott und mensch da tut mir leid aber
ihr seht schon es ist ein sehr kluger
todd ist dass der conti auf jeden fall
hoch match du schaffst es natürlich wenn
es einer schaffen kann dann unser guter
test auf dem weg
comstage wir haben ja zeitnah also der
tod der ist jetzt auf jeden fall seine
aufgabe ist hier eine miene zu bauen in
dem areal was ich je gemacht habe ich
helfe man ganz kurz hier genauso wenn
sie das aus der mode zu graben und das
coole ist die das dings oder ist das
gerät auch weiter wenn der topf nicht
vorhanden ist der topf fällt da
wahrscheinlich wieder direkt runter dort
wird hundertprozentig der fall sein
darunter kann jeder herzlich noch fest
mit einer spitzhacke das ist ja ein
cooler typ
der wird aber gleich wieder darunter
fallen und der graf sich griff sich
jetzt hier auf jeden fall die nie und
wenn wir die kiste gruppen sehen wir
69er der 60er de 61 aspekt sich hoch
weil natürlich wird man hier mit der
mine gewinn machen und die ganze erde
wird davongetragen und ihr seht da unten
ist zum beispiel greve dann bekomme ich
nachher noch kreml in die kiste und das
wird dann halt alles gelagert
also das ist die mine jetzt können wir
trotz einfach feiern lässt sich feiern
das w o a hockey sondern dass wir feuern
so tust du kommst jetzt einfach mal zu
mir was ich hätte mir ganz kurz daraus
so kommen wird genau klasse typ
jetzt habe ich auch schon mal die farm
jetzt können wir die marke wieder
abnehmen
die brauchen mich erstmal nicht mehr
deswegen sagt ich auf meinem bauch
höchstens dreimal kleinen vierten
braucht man nicht der typ der läuft uns
direkt wegen zeit immer lieber ganz
schnell hier bilden constructor der topf
weg und zwar setze ich wieder hier einst
hin
79 noch hier einzelnen und wartet
manchmal ganz kurz hier noch einen
ebenen boden
dann setze ich hier noch ein hin soll es
habe ich dass stevia im chat jordan
bleibe dann schlechter vor einen
building constructor block und natürlich
hier wieder eine kiste wenn ich jetzt
hier einfach draufklicken bilder ist es
dann diesmal tengel fort so dann hab ich
natürlich geheiratet erfolg müsst euch
keine kredite mehr
das setzt natürlich blöd die sache ist
die man braucht für alle aktionen die
man irgendwie plant braucht man simyo
credits das heißt sie aids ist das geld
was ihr nachher hat man kriegt bei jedem
neuen tag
simyo credits das heißt immer wenn die
sonne aufgeht ich weiß nicht wen ich
doch jetzt hier einfach mal times at
night mache an der weser times saturday
ich hätte mich nicht damit da muss er
nicht mehr abwarten
jedenfalls kann ich den ist nicht heilen
weil ich kein geld habe das heißt mich
auf ok klicken
juni zum single trails das ist natürlich
blöd deswegen würde ich einfach sagen
dass wir so ganz spontan ergeben so hin
creative gehen
jetzt haben wir die gleichen plätze dass
er wird leute ich würd mal ganz kurz
sagen lass ich mal ganz kurz ein kleines
stoff mache und mache mir gleich zu
einer creative city welt damit ich euch
dann einfach zeigen kann oder bzw
damit ich dann einfach den dänen den
tops anheuern kann dass er eine farm
aufbaut also hier ist der tod allerdings
habe ich nur ich hab's camino schulden
also ich habe - 19 10
dann seien die farmen uns natürlich ein
bisschen gekostet hat uns mut gemacht
deshalb den song gehört weil es das
alles ein bisschen was gekostet hat
deswegen würde ich ja sagen wir sind
sofort wieder so freunde und hier bin
ich zurück in minecraft vor ein paar
sekunden für mich war okay 20 sekunden
ist die saison sehr viel mehr aber
dadurch kann ich euch jetzt einfach das
startmenü mal ein bisschen zeit um mir
natürlich gut vorbereitet hier sind nun
vier verschiedenen modi normal kreativ
parcours und trotzdem ihr kraft in hart
kommt habe ich vorhin einfach verdrängt
einfach nicht so wichtig deshalb
eigentlich nur den hart und wir gehen
jetzt einfach ein creative mode
sie müssen natürlich wieder von vorne
anfangen aber unsere open ein gott
wir sind direkt vor dem tempel respond
freunde ihr seht ihr wisst ja ich bin
immer so ein bisschen neugierig schaut
man zu freuen
was geht denn hier so zu entdecken und
bitten hier sollten ja kaum schiffe mit
pfeilen ab auch in die ammann be over
also wenn ihr die haben weil ich hab
immer ein händchen für sie da ist er ein
guter brauch jetzt erstmal nicht so also
wir sind jetzt nun in der creative fällt
das heißt wir haben genug genügend geld
wir haben wir haben endlich geld sind
sehr schöne landschaft also wenn ihr
ziel haben wollt hier ist schreibt euch
ganz gut macht pause und ja also ich
mache ja gerade mal ganz kurz ein
bisschen platz der mahlzeit freuden aber
kein zeitdruck bin ja vorbereitet jetzt
nicht kommentare schreiben helfen könnte
überhaupt keine ahnung ich dachte
einfach nur ich hatte eine creative feld
gemacht ich hätte genug kohle hatte ich
aber nicht tut mir dann dementsprechend
jetzt auch leid ich habe ganz gute
sachen zurück was ich brauche und zwar
einen marker eine erste astronaut
interview also das ist wenn ihr jetzt in
kraft aktiviert dann kommt dort immer
leute in eure gegen 3
denn da hinten ist so ich mache es mal
ganz kurz hier so eine fläche das heißt
ich setze hier ein hin front läuft ihr
wisst es front wright und dann einfach
setz dich mal hier noch ein hin und nun
waren wir natürlich stehen bei den
bildern constructor das heißt die drei
müssen übrigens alle auf einer höhe sein
das heißt wenn ich jetzt an den
constructor vorsätze die kiste und ihr
heimrecht an bilder den terrier
blablabla klicke einfach auf ok kann ich
nun ein building ausschüssen
da nehme ich mal zuerst angel und dann
gibt's jede menge häuser da unten sind
immer die leute von denen die gebaut
wurden darüber sind die kosten lässt zum
beispiel in zwei story aus costa rei sie
macht sich aber im maschinenhaus zb 18
schüler leon bzw konkret tauern kostet
so viel das ist schön so ein ganz ganz
leise könnte menge bauen
allerdings möchte ich ein smarter source
deswegen kann ich und einfach
draufklicken an sich ist moritz sachen
nehme doch einfach mal das von was ist
ein mittlerer preis das ist ein
mittlerer preis so bildet
jetzt will sie das büffeln ok die steht
jetzt hier und denkt sich so wenig war
das jetzt allerdings buildings morlock
kabinen und schaut mal was im chat steht
allerdings mal locker wie noch das ist
eine ganz schnelle und dies direkt
fertig ich dachte eigentlich wollen noch
ein paar sachen allerdings david pratt
of modern das euch grad total vergessen
eigentlich wenn sie so ein haus bauen
sondern ihr seid im normalen modus müsst
ihr in die kiste die sachen reinlegen
die ihr für dieses haus braucht also zb
sagt ihr euch dann ja ihr braucht holz
und alles mögliche und das müsste dann
als in die kiste lägen allerdings gleich
erkannt im creative bin muss ich das
muss ich das nicht machen allerdings
sieht das ganze haus so aus ist sie ist
ein kleiner fehler dass das hier alles
noch ein bisschen nicht daran kommt so
das muss hier nämlich eigentlich so
aussehen und diese firmen das muss
eigentlich so aussehen dass die ganzen
sachen hier oben ist auch so aussehen
als ich denke ihr wisst wie ich das
meine ich ein paar fehler die noch
proben werden müssen
allerdings kann man jetzt hier reingehen
und ihr seht schon hier ist also eine
box drin und wenn man einfach richtig
drauf macht dann ist das eine building
control panel jetzt sagt euch an was ist
hinaus ist buildings morlok teil
präsident ausgewählt und es ist ein
headset haus also von harriet medtech so
das ding kann auch herum herum
teleportieren sage ich mal dafür
brauchen wir sie biomarkern alles
allerdings verlinke ich euch einfach ja
dem motto die modifikation und inter
beschreiben könnt ihr euch selber
angucken ist jetzt allerdings auch erst
mal ganz egal was das alles bis sondern
ich zeige euch jetzt noch ganz kurz
neben die fahne kommen die fresse so wir
bei uns doch ganz kurz eine faden ich
mache hier ein ding da man hier wieder
ob ich muss dich erwecken dem fällt mir
doch auch sonst funktioniert das nämlich
alles auch nicht so gemeint ist
natürlich noch einer
und hier ist auch noch eine
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla zack
zack zack
wenn ich jetzt hier eine farming box
vorstelle mit einer kiste
der nervt mich irgendwie kann ich jetzt
hier einfach heyer farmer machen da habe
ich jetzt hier zum beispiel zwei sondern
zb einfach mal dem martin weil dann kann
ich auswählen verfahren kartfahren
potato farben formen und farben
ich nehme einfach mal die mitfahren und
dann können wir das upgraden so das
erste was gebaut wird es ein zaun und
jetzt macht der gene hier da wie im
creative nutzen geht das alles total
schnell der macht uns jetzt erstmal ganz
fix gefahren hin
natürlich ohne wasser sehr klar als auch
der wasser mit reinbringen und leben wir
denn
aber wieso sind denke ich gerade marken
hingesetzt
ich weiß nicht warum da ist was ich hab
da zumindest kann hingesetzt
das macht der body farm packt uns auch
die sachen hin
und ja also dass es die fahren die kann
ihr hier auf euch auch bauen
und wenn ich da zum beispiel hier mal
wieder also die könnte ich jetzt weg
nehmen und ihr wisst ja ach mist jetzt
läuft er danke und danke ich kann jetzt
auch hier einfach mal wieder hingehen
hier einfach ein
und hier und da setze ich hier einfach
auch noch ein hin
hier kann ich jetzt einfach building
construction blog vorsätzen kiste
brauche ich eigentlich nicht vorsetzen
wegwart im creative tings bin aber naja
so die mir nämlich jetzt einfach mal
jetzt kann ich hier ein bisschen was
auswählen mich keine zrfv maria nehmen
zb zealand machen da macht sie dann
wasser zu land wenn ihr wasser drin ist
es könnte ich da in den see machen was
kann ich denn hier so machen ich nimmer
value pack bin also das ist dann der
radius um das gemüt passieren werde ich
nehme einfach mal 10
dann kann ich hier einfach value pack
auswählen und da steht der junge star
tara vor mach so weiter der momente
musik und zum terror format verfügbar
den ich jetzt irgendwie ich möchte ich
gerne feiern
so feiere harry terry formblatt ok terra
form area
so jetzt geht die nämlich hier einmal
ganz kurz die noch ein paar blöcke hin
damit ihr seht was damit meines so dass
lost count to work jahr anfang als mann
schüttelt mit dem kopf
mach was und wann hast du hier taking
the weather forecast sohle der schaut
sich die wettervorhersage an so und du
dir das mal zu arbeiten hatte floss
arbeite los warum schild dem kopflos
zusatzarbeiten arbeite ich habe gesagt
arbeiten
na gut dann freiwillig mal ganz kurz und
ich zeige euch noch mal ganz kurz dass
wir hier noch etwas anderes erzählen
bauen
wir brauchen jetzt einfach mal nochmal
resident shell allerdings konnten wir
bauen den anderen dahin so und jetzt hat
sie hier diesen komischen knüppel da und
checkt ob sie die building resources hat
guckt deswegen in die kiste realisiert
in der kiste sind natürlich keine
zutaten allerdings der luca befindet
sich im creative mode das heißt ich habe
die ganzen zutaten oder malen die macht
jetzt natürlich die farm von martin
kaputter müsse dann natürlich schon mal
ein bisschen planen sie gerade voller
größe nachschauen
allerdings bot jetzt hier sollen sich
auf und na ja ich will erst mal sagen
das was von der modifikation ich hab
euch die grundlegenden sachen gezeigt
wenn ihr interesse an der modifikation
habt dann schaut doch einfach mal den
die beschreibung wird findet ihr einen
download-link
ich finds auf jeden fall eine klasse
idee dass sowas umzusetzen und das wars
auch möglich ist wird jetzt gerade mein
schöner traum eine residenz wird gerade
gebaut
ihr könnt das natürlich dann oft weiter
mache einfach wie ihr wollt ihr hier
jetzt nicht alles fertig da hat jetzt
mehr aufgemacht ist ja unwichtig sonntag
niemand wollen wir hier den eingang
jetzt überhaupt hier ist ein kleiner
balkon
den eigenen direkt hier ich schaue ich
gebe einfach durch also sieht dann diese
residenz aus kann ich dann ja auch
wieder gucken residenz blah blah blah
joint place wer hier drin daher gerade
in der nähe ist und was alles und
arbeitet er an der marke was macht der
martin gerade und das ist die art die
die wandert einfach rum
martin der ist relaxing aktiv form das
ist ein ganz cooler bauer
naja wenn es euch gefallen da will ich
mich auf jeden fall über einen daumen
hoch freund schreibt aber in die
kommentare was euch am besten gefallen
hat beziehen was wir verbessern würde im
gegensatz jetzt also außer mods oder so
was würdet ihr also außerhalb bugs
nichtnutzer wachstum
was würdet ihr noch hinzufügen was wird
euch freuen also schreibt mir das
einfach in die kommentare
alles ist in der beschreibung twitter
facebook etc ja